[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast
and uh also even money podcast you can
find him on social media at ross tucker
nfl i saw an article in the la times and
uh the gist of the article is who has
the most pressure on them in the super
bowl and the la times was saying
it's
sean mcvay
you buy into that
yeah that was going to be my initial
reaction really i mean it's nobody on
the bengals
i mean it's nobody on the bengals
obviously nobody expected him to be here
i think you could say matthew stafford
but he's already won three playoff games
he already got them to the super bowl
further than jared goff did the only
person here who has the ability really
to accomplish something that they have
missed out on to this point
is mcveigh
because not only did they lose that
super bowl to the patriots but they
couldn't score i mean he's an offensive
genius whiz guru
they could not score against the
patriots in that super bowl i don't
think there's that much pressure on
anybody to be honest with you but if
there is one person that has the biggest
onus on them in this game it's probably
mcveigh
let's look at the last couple of days in
the nfl let me let me start with uh jim
harbaugh what question or questions do
you have with harbaugh going back to
michigan
how bad he wants to get back in the nfl
i mean like to me it it
this makes me laugh dan
you know you see last night
multiple reports jim harbaugh has called
michigan
he wants to come back and be there
and then like 15 minutes later the
vikings are expected to hire kevin
o'connell as their head coach you know
like everybody does this yeah i mean
from now on anytime head coach interview
i'm gonna call the ross tucker podcast
and be like i'm gonna stay i'm going to
stay as soon as i find out somebody else
gets the head job i'm going to stay
going on dan patrick every week like
give me a break dude i don't understand
national signing
i wonder if harbaugh went there
expecting for the vikings to sell
him on the vikings organization and it
feels like the vikings said to jim
harbaugh
we want you to sell yourself to us
and i think you're there for nine hours
i mean you don't go through nine hours
without getting a job if you're jim
harbaugh i'm thinking but i think he
went into that interview and maybe it
was like i'm here
hire me and minnesota probably went nah
it doesn't work that way jim we want to
know what you can do for the
organization
well i think that's possible
at a minimum he wouldn't go
for a nine hour interview to minnesota
on national signing day and i know it's
the second signing day but still he
wouldn't do that unless he wanted the
job i believe he wanted the job you know
there have been so many rumors for last
few weeks that he really wants to get
back to the nfl i don't blame him
recruiting is
24 7. and what i personally think
happened is as soon as he caught wind or
his agent caught wind that he wasn't
getting the job he wanted to make it
look like he was turning them down it's
not you it you know it's me it's not you
that's not the case i'm pretty confident
he wanted the job
and if you're the new gm
for the vikings do you really want your
first hire
to be bringing a guy
who it ended really poorly the last time
because he got into a power struggle
with the gm i mean this would be a first
time gm
my guy quezie from princeton who's
younger than me makes me feel bad about
myself and now he's a gm of an nfl team
he didn't want to bring it i wouldn't
think you would want to bring in a guy
that could lead to a power struggle i
don't think it'll happen with kevin
o'connell
yeah and then i wonder
if i'm stephen ross and the timing is
horrible but steven ross didn't want to
poach harbaugh from michigan but if he
knows that minnesota is going to poach
him from michigan then what would stop
steven ross from
not trying to poach him because jim
wants to go to the nfl but giving the
timing of what happened in the brian
flores stuff it probably felt like
you know jim can't go play for steven
wrong stephen ross may not have this
team in a year with everything that's
gone on what do you make of the
allegations against the dolphins and
their owner
well that's the one that jumped out to
me the most you know all of the rooney
rule
coach hiring stuff
um is of course a huge topic but it's
one that we broach every offseason i
mean we talk about that every office it
doesn't make it better and i'd be
incredibly frustrated if i was a
minority head coach candidate but what's
new this year
in this lawsuit what jumped out to me
was the allegations of being
incentivized to lose games which is a
major major problem i mean if there's
any evidence of that
the nfl is going to come down on him
as hard as they ever have they're gonna
take his team away
you think they will
for that where you're you're fixing
games
i mean it's bribing it's it's it's
a bribery act
you can't just find him a million or 10
million or 20 million it doesn't matter
to him
he's throwing games he wants you to
throw games allegedly and paying you to
do it
you can't let him he can't stay because
he wants to get joe burrow
i mean that's why he was doing this
i can't let him have his team
yeah so the thing i always think is
interesting about that is dan if that's
the case then or if if what hugh
jackson's saying is accurate are you
getting rid of haslem and steven ross
and if you're one of
the 32 owners or 31 i guess that makes
this decision
are you really comfortable with getting
rid of two of those i mean those guys
don't want to think that there's
anything that can get them out of the
club they're in the club they bought in
my guest dan and you know more than i do
i guess but i would think it'd be like
three first round picks and 10 million
dollars i think it would be the most
severe punishment a team and an owner
has ever gotten
i i don't know if they're gonna kick out
two owners of this exclusive club
because then the other owner's gonna be
like wait a minute if we can kick out
this guy for that and that guy for that
they might come come at me for something
at some point
well i think cleveland is different
because hugh jackson didn't get money he
just got his contract extended
like i think the owner thought hey this
is a couple years rebuild and you're
doing really well at
doing really poorly and we want to keep
you in that job so they didn't say for
each
loss uh you get a hundred thousand
dollars they're just saying hey if you
keep losing we're going to continue to
extend your contract
now is that semantics
but
the direction is not lose games and you
get a hundred thousand dollars that's
the difference that's where it gets far
more severe with steven ross yeah i
guess because here's my question okay
and i tweeted about this this morning at
ross tucker nfl dan i'm a sixers fan
okay now i'm not a die-hard nba guy you
know i'm a football guy but
the sixers essentially lost on purpose
for like four years in a row i mean i
think it's it's interesting to me
that the browns and the dolphins are
under fire
when i don't know i don't follow it that
close again but don't aren't there
several nba teams that essentially lose
on purpose every year the cabs did this
for lebron james
you know the rockets did this uh for i
think for kim elijah one i mean this is
this is this happens that but why has
nobody why have they never gotten in
trouble like why has nobody ever ever
nobody ever been an issue i guess no
coach said anything well the sixers
called it the process
see that's the difference
that that's the difference it's the
process
it's it's not tanking you can't say
tanking mark cuban used the word tanking
and they got fined six hundred thousand
dollars it's the process there we're
talking ross tucker his ross tucker
football podcast is available uh
well wherever you can get podcast and
social media ross tucker nfl
i don't know why jimbo fisher isn't just
embracing the obvious and that is we got
resources at texas a m and this is a
great place to play and we beat alabama
we're here we're for real but instead
he had this reaction yesterday to
the reported slush fund that a m has
that's somewhere between 25 and 30
million dollars for the recruits
there is no 30 million dollar fund there
is no 5 million there is no 10 this is
garbage and it does it pisses me off and
here it comes from a site called bro
bible by a guy named sliced bread then
everybody runs with it so it's written
on the internet as gospel how
irresponsible is that and then to have
coaches
and our leg and across this league who
say it clown acts all right
irresponsible as hell multiple coaches
in our league and the guy's griping
about nil griping about transfer
reporter using it the most and bragging
about it the most that's the ironic part
you want character i'll trust i'll take
it with any y'all it's a joke it does
piss me off okay you know what i would
do if if i'm him i would say no no it's
on 25 or 30 minutes it's 50 million we
have in a name imagine like the slush
phone there's a whole lot more where
that came from come on down here and
play with the aggies
well a couple things there number one
uh what's the line me thinks he doth
protest too much you know i think he
went
a little far there secondly
look i've been around long enough to
know remember the year when ole miss got
laramie tonsil and laquan treadwell and
like i mean when a school
that isn't a typically a top five
recruiting school and texas a m does
pretty well usually but not top five not
number one in the country when they come
out of nowhere to be the number one
school
there's usually a reason for that what i
think is unique or different about this
is
as far as i know you're kind of allowed
now i read the rule where they say
it's not supposed to be
an inducement for someone to attend to
school it's supposed to just be money
that they earn from their image and
likeness while they're actually at the
school
but this is what i always thought it
would turn into
and it has and i'm happy for the kids
i'm happy that they're getting the money
and this is what i always thought it
would be which is essentially
guaranteeing every kid hey you'll get at
least 100 grand a year in name image and
likeness but i'm the i'm a backup center
we don't care we need depth 100 grand a
year buddy you're in
yeah they made it legal and this is you
know the the ncaa
just wanted to make sure that these kids
weren't getting paid money that was
going to be for the schools
playoffs all of that hey we don't want
to pay the players but we'll let you
have name image and likeness and no one
thought this through
that the schools who have money willing
to spend money and yes it's an
i'll go there and you're going to pay me
for name image and likeness but how much
are you going to pay me for name image
and likeness so then it becomes an
inducement because nobody there's no
salary cap that says you can only offer
them this
well legally
i can offer you whatever i want and so
if if texas a m has the money and
they're willing to spend the money like
i wouldn't be apologizing
dan i was told
three years ago
by a personnel director at a power five
school
that the nil department
would end up being bigger than the
recruiting department
at these schools
sooner rather than later i mean
this is going to be
what goes a long way towards determining
where these kids go
i don't blame them
you know who knows if you'll make the
nfl or not they're essentially free
agents the the part that gets really
interesting is that they can all
transfer for a year i'll give you
another one dan i've had multiple
coaches tell me that you know why they
love the transfer portal you know why
they want to get more transfers
because you only get to do it without
penalty once
you recruit a high school kid to come in
he's a perpetual free agent you know you
get you get to transfer one time without
sitting out at all that kid can leave
whenever you get a transfer from
somewhere else
he's got to make it work
he's he's got to stay there otherwise if
he tries to transfer again unless he's a
graduate he has to sit out a year so
they actually feel like there's a chance
for more loyalty
from the kid it's a it's a the whole
thing has changed it's wild
you played for the washington
redskins six games i believe so i
curious the uh your old team with the
new nickname
you're a commander
yeah i guess i really wanted to be a i i
would have really embraced warthogs
or red hogs i i wanted something to go
back to the hogs
i actually started my career there and
finished it there
so i have somewhat of an affinity for
them not like i do for the bills where i
played the most or whatever
i mean commanders reminds me of the
cleveland indians changing the name of
the guardians it just seems so uh it's
such an xfl
type of name to me the commanders
it's just very generic i mean i guess
it's fine dan i guess it's safe
but let me ask you this okay
when someone says to my daughters or
says to me
you know hey ross what teams did you
play for
cowboys bills patriots browns
for the fifth one am i saying commanders
or am i saying redskins because i played
for the redskins or am i not saying that
because that is obviously offensive to
some people i mean that name's no longer
around i would say washington
but then that sounds weird
cowboys bills patriots browns and
washington
i wanted to say i was a warthog i think
that's awesome i don't know why they
didn't go with the warthogs i'm still
bothered by this uh i know you have a
new business venture that you wanted to
mention here to our own oh i appreciate
that dan yeah it's awesome it's the
greatest valentine's day gift ever it's
called
myfrontpagestory.com everybody just gets
flowers or chocolates or
a gift card to a spa when they open it
dan it literally looks like it's on the
cover of the newspaper it's a framed
newspaper cover story with the picture
of your wife the family she'll be like
what is this honey my wife
anybody's wife oh whoever whoever you
get the story for you i'm assuming you
would get it for your wife for
valentine's day so it's a picture of
your wife maybe your kids and your
wife's like dan what is this and you're
like honey i want to do something
special and unique i care i had a story
written about you i get way too much pub
i get way too much attention to dan
patrick the story the cover story should
be about you and then when she reads the
quote stan and by the way i've heard you
talk about this like on my buddy kyle
brandt's podcast when she reads the
quotes about i just never tell her
enough how much i appreciate all the
little things she does she will cry like
your wife or anybody's what fritzy
fritzy's probably gonna get his wife uh
you know a gift card to the olive garden
again fritz that's 12 years in a row an
olive garden gift what's wrong with that
story from
story.com
well todd has limericks and he writes
his wife a limerick
not as good as this well maybe not trust
me you know i was just saying to the
guys the other day when i think of love
i think of ross tucker
and nothing else
so i would like to get a picture of you
and then i would be able to present that
to my wife
that would be awesome i'm sure i'm sure
she would love that
you got any uh like
scandily clad
you're sure
back in college
does she want does she want to see like
310 pounds yeah baby yeah
that's what i mean the only
pictures i have with my shirt off
are like at a keg party in the summer
when i was in college
i'm actually i actually think for 310 i
looked all right i was pretty tan not
too bad
but you know here's the thing dan i
don't know about your wife
a lot of women are not into that like
when i was in college and i would go to
a party okay you could tell right away i
mean i was 315 pounds girls either like
that or they don't and there's no in
between and you know right away most
girls are not like blow drying their
hair hoping to meet up the perfect 315
pound guy that night okay it doesn't
work that way if you had been able to
get into notre dame then they might have
cared but you went to princeton those
those women don't care about football at
princeton
so that is a fact okay that it does not
it doesn't help you
to be
a princeton football player at princeton
but i would go visit like my buddies at
penn state and they'd be like are you a
football player and i'd be like you're
darn right i am i didn't say it wasn't
at penn state i just said you're done
right and it worked every time every
time
if i could do if i could do college over
again i would go to one of those that
would be uh that would be princeton was
amazing i'm glad i had that experience
but man
i'll go to texas a m get the money and
the girls
thank you ross good to talk to you
ross tucker football podcast and you can
find him on social media at ross tucker
nfl